Si nous tous nous sommes ici d'accord pour dire au moment que Christ est le point culminant de l'histoire,
alors nous avons besoin de lire l'Ancien Testament, nous avons besoin de comprendre l'Ancien Testament
pour comprendre pourquoi Christ est le point culminant de l'histoire.
Et là, c'est le même principe, si aujourd'hui vous avez un livre,
si vous prenez un livre, un roman ou n'importe quel livre, vous commencez à le lire à la fin,
ça ne va pas être intéressant.
Il y a des choses, vous n'allez pas comprendre tout le...
Si vous lisez à la fin et vous voyez, on a attrapé le meurtrier, vous allez vous dire, mais comment ça s'est passé avant ?
Donc, généralement, on commence à lire un livre au début pour pouvoir comprendre l'intrigue,
et à la fin, on arrive à mieux comprendre.
Donc, en d'autres mots, si à un moment, on n'a pas cette possibilité d'avoir étudié l'Ancien Testament
et ce qu'il peut nous enseigner, ce sera très difficile de pouvoir saisir l'œuvre de Christ.
Et donc, pour conclure avec cette introduction, donc aujourd'hui, on sera beaucoup plus sur l'introduction,
mais là, je vais conclure avec l'introduction, la grande introduction.
Donc, pour conclure, c'est très important pour nous que pour saisir le sens de la grandeur de Dieu,
pour saisir la majesté de son plan, pour saisir, je vais même dire le mot, la ténacité de son amour,
parce que c'est ce qui va ressortir de l'Ancien Testament,
il n'y a rien qui puisse remplacer l'Ancien Testament.
Pour comprendre vraiment ce sens de grandeur de Dieu, sa majesté,
si nous nous coupons de l'Ancien Testament, nous nous privons d'une partie de la révélation de Dieu
et notre Dieu va sembler, et ça c'est les mots, notre Dieu va sembler plus petit,
notre Dieu va sembler moins saint,
et notre Dieu va même sembler moins aimable qu'il n'est l'air réellement.
Donc là, la Bible en entier, quel est le but pour nous ?
Là aujourd'hui, comme je vous ai dit, nous sommes dans l'introduction de ça,
et la première chose importante que nous devons voir, c'est la grande image.
C'est la grande image, et donc ça fait en lien avec ce que je viens de vous dire.
Si on regarde depuis des siècles, la Bible n'a laissé personne d'indifférent.
C'est-à-dire que si maintenant vous lancez, vous trouvez 4, 5 personnes,
et vous dites qu'est-ce que vous pensez de la Bible,
il y a des gens qui vont apprécier la Bible,
il y a des personnes qui vont dire à un moment que la Bible est la source,
il y a même certains qui disent que c'est la source de tous les maux de la Terre.
S'il n'y avait pas la Bible, s'il n'y avait pas la religion,
aujourd'hui les gens seraient en paix.
Donc on a eu des personnes, par exemple, pendant le siècle des Lumières en France,
à un moment les philosophes du siècle des Lumières,
ont combattu la Bible.
D'ailleurs même Voltaire avait dit à un moment que d'ici 200 ans,
donc il était au 18e siècle, il disait qu'au début du 20e siècle,
la Bible aurait disparu, parce que les hommes seraient devenus sages,
ils n'auraient plus vu la nécessité d'avoir la Bible.
Vous avez le régime communiste,
et même beaucoup d'autres régimes autoritaires aujourd'hui
qui interdisent la Bible,
parce que pour eux, comme ils le disaient,
ils savaient la vérité, ils savaient la profondeur,
ils savaient le travail que la Bible peut faire,
l'impact, je voulais dire, l'impact de la Bible.
Et dans les régimes communistes,
ils en parlaient comme une collection de contes et de légendes.
Donc ça, on voit un moment que la Bible ne laisse personne indifférent.
Une chose aussi qui est très importante,
quand je veux vous parler de cette grande image,
pourquoi nous devons voir la Bible dans un sens en entier d'abord,
dans ce sens de grande image,
c'est qu'on a des personnes aussi qui ont une grande foi dans la Bible,
ils vont te dire un moment, je crois en la parole de Dieu,
mais la grande foi dans la Bible,
ce n'est pas une garantie que les gens comprennent la Bible.
Et donc, vous avez par exemple des personnes,
il y avait là, quand je préparais l'étude,
j'avais vu, il y avait un roi,
le Ménélique II d'Éthiopie,
qui lui, dans sa compréhension de la Bible,
à un moment, quand il est tombé malade,
il s'est mis à déchirer les pages de la Bible et à les manger.
Il était sûr qu'en mangeant les pages de la Bible,
il allait guérir.
Et à un moment, il a fait ça,
et je crois qu'il était même déjà arrivé au livre de deux rois
quand il est mort,
et ça ne l'a pas guéri.
Mais là, il était en train de mal comprendre
ce que Dieu lui demandait.
La Bible est, je pense,
le livre le plus vendu de toute l'histoire de l'humanité.
C'est à la fois le livre le plus acheté,
mais c'est à la fois le livre qui est le moins lu
par ceux qui le possèdent.
Si vous allez voir souvent,
il y a des gens qui vont dire,
oui, j'ai une Bible.
Vous allez lui dire,
est-ce que tu as déjà ouvert ta Bible ?
Il va dire, non, je n'ai pas ouvert la Bible,
c'est dans la famille depuis des années,
je ne l'ouvre pas.
Et c'est un peu dans ce sens,
voilà pourquoi nous sommes en train de faire cette étude.
C'est un peu dans ce sens aussi
d'essayer de dépoussiérer les vérités
qui sont portées par rapport à la parole
pour que nous puissions prendre conscience
du trésor qu'on a.
Si on, alors ce qui est sûr,
comme je vous ai dit,
nous sommes en train de faire un survol,
parce que si nous nous mettons à étudier
sérieusement la Bible,
la vie de chacun de nous ne suffirait pas
pour comprendre ce que la Bible dit.
Et vous voyez même la conclusion de Jean à la fin,
il va dire un moment,
le Seigneur Jésus-Christ a dit tellement,
tellement de choses,
mais il faudrait des livres et des livres
pour pouvoir apporter tout ce qu'il a dit.
Donc la Bible,
la Bible c'est pas moins de,
combien de livres ?
La Bible c'est pas moins de 66 livres,
ce sont des livres dans l'ensemble.
Quand je vous parle de la grande image
que nous devons avoir,
la Bible,
ce sont des histoires,
ce sont des codes de la loi,
ce sont des maximes éthiques,
ce sont des traités de philosophie,
ce sont des discours,
ce sont des drames,
on va lire des histoires,
on va lire,
il y a des hymnes,
il y a des biographies,
il y a des lettres officielles,
il y a des lettres plus personnelles,
il y a beaucoup de choses.
On voit aussi que,
par rapport à la Bible,
les écrivains de la Bible
venaient d'origines diverses.
Par exemple,
vous avez des écrivains,
ça va partir de l'Égypte ancienne,
on est presque sur du moins,
moins 4000 avant Jésus-Christ,
à la Rome impériale,
avec Auguste,
et là nous sommes à peu près
à plusieurs années après Jésus-Christ.
Donc nous voyons que il y a,
donc les écrivains,
les auteurs de la Bible
sont de diversité,
sont de plusieurs diversités,
mais une des choses qui reste là,
au milieu de toutes ces diversités,
c'est que nous voyons un fil rouge,
nous voyons une sorte de fil conducteur
qui relie chacune des parties de la Bible,
qui relie chaque livre de la Bible,
et si aujourd'hui,
il nous arrivait,
il arrivait qu'il manque un de ces livres,
même là,
une des compréhensions du plan de Dieu,
nous perdrions une des compréhensions
du plan de Dieu.
Et Dieu,
dans sa souveraineté,
dans sa provision,
a voulu qu'au travers des siècles,
Dieu a permis que ces livres soient préservés,
et qu'aujourd'hui,
ces livres constituent
le canon qui a été retenu,
même au niveau des apôtres
et des pères de l'Église.
Quand on lit la Bible,
et c'est ça qui est important,
parce que souvent,
certaines personnes
qui ne vont pas étudier
l'Ancien Testament,
ne vont pas le faire à cause de ça,
c'est que souvent,
on dissocie,
on va considérer un moment
qu'il y a un Dieu
différent dans l'Ancien Testament,
et un Dieu,
disons les mots,
il y a un Dieu plus méchant,
plus dur dans l'Ancien Testament,
et un Dieu plus gentil
dans le Nouveau Testament.
Mais la vérité qu'il y a,
c'est que pendant tous les 66 livres
de la Bible,
c'est la même doctrine
qui est enseignée du début à la fin.
C'est un livre qui est
en plusieurs parties,
mais qui est entier dans son contenu.
Pour mieux comprendre aussi
un des exemples
que je peux vous donner,
je pense que vous avez déjà vu
de la photographie en accéléré.
Si vous avez déjà vu
ce genre de photos
où il y a des personnes
qui vont par exemple
filmer l'aurore boréale,
on va placer l'appareil photo
à un endroit fixe,
et on laisse le temps passer,
et il prend l'image,
il prend l'image,
pendant,
donc ça veut dire,
on peut placer la caméra
le matin,
à midi,
ça prend l'image,
et ça prend tout le changement.
Et pour vous,
je pense que vous avez saisi l'image,
vous avez déjà pu voir ça ?
Donc pour comprendre ça,
vous pouvez voir
que les écritures
représentent un peu
l'appareil photo,
c'est-à-dire les écritures
sont là,
les écritures
sont témoins des siècles,
les siècles passent,
mais les écritures demeurent.
et c'est pour ça
que c'est très important
pour nous
que nous devons comprendre
que le principe de la Bible,
l'Ancien Testament,
ce sont des promesses
que Dieu a faites.
Le Nouveau Testament,
c'est l'accomplissement
des promesses
qui ont été faites
dans l'Ancien Testament.
et c'est tout cela
qui constitue le message
le plus important
pour l'humanité.
Donc mon encouragement,
par exemple,
ce matin,
pour ceux qui ont signalé,
par exemple,
de ne jamais avoir fini
l'Ancien Testament,
moi, mon encouragement,
ce serait que dans votre
prochain programme
de lecture de la parole,
que vous puissiez inclure
le fait de l'Ancien Testament.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que justement,
comme on a dit,
c'est ce qui permet
de comprendre tout l'ensemble.
si nous arrivons juste
aux promesses
qui sont accomplies
et que nous n'arrivons pas
à voir les promesses
qui avaient été faites avant,
nous n'arrivons pas
à saisir l'importance
de pourquoi ces promesses
ont été accomplies.
Donc,
quand nous allons partir,
je pense que là,
c'était clair pour vous expliquer
un peu la grande image,
de comprendre l'importance,
en fait,
de considérer la Bible
comme un tout.
Là, maintenant,
nous allons partir
sur cette partie
des promesses
qui sont faites.
Donc,
le message
de l'Ancien Testament.
Et c'est sur ça
que vont porter
les messages
pratiquement,
comme je dis,
je l'ai rappelé,
ce sera des études,
un panorama,
un survol de la Bible,
des 39 livres
de l'Ancien Testament.
Et après,
nous ferons certainement
le Nouveau Testament.
Voilà.
Donc,
là,
nous allons aborder
les promesses
qui sont faites.
Et les promesses
qui sont faites,
elles sont faites
dans l'Ancien Testament.
C'est le message
de l'Ancien Testament.
Donc,
déjà,
ce que je suis en train
de dire,
c'est que ce n'est pas
tout le monde
qui va considérer
la Bible comme un tout.
Il y a certaines personnes
qui ignorent volontairement
l'Ancien Testament.
Peut-être que là,
quand je vous ai demandé,
il y a certains,
du fait de ne jamais avoir
fini l'Ancien Testament,
c'est qu'il y a certaines parties
qu'ils ignorent volontairement
ou ils ne trouvent pas
d'intérêt pour la lecture.
Il y a eu,
au deuxième siècle,
après le Sien,
Jésus-Christ,
il y a eu un certain Martion
qui avait des disciples aussi
et Martion avait choisi
de considérer
certains passages
de la Bible.
Donc,
à un moment,
il avait,
il rejetait avec ses disciples,
il rejetait tout le livre
de l'Ancien Testament
et il considérait juste
dix épîtres de Paul
et l'évangile de Luc.
Et tout le reste,
ils avaient rejeté.
C'est un peu ça.
Souvent,
nous allons trouver
qu'il y a certains chrétiens
qui font un peu comme Martion
et qui vont choisir
d'ignorer l'Ancien Testament.
Ils vont apprécier
l'Ancien Testament
parce qu'ils vont trouver
des histoires
comme celle de Moïse,
comme celle de Joseph,
de David.
Ils vont même trouver
un certain romantisme
dans les psaumes
et dans les proverbes,
mais ils vont ignorer
le reste.
Ils vont dire,
par exemple,
Nombre,
je ne trouve pas l'intérêt
de lire Nombre,
c'est barbant,
c'est ennuant.
Malheureusement,
pour ceux qui agissent
ainsi,
si nous sommes en train
de faire cette négligence,
nous sommes en train
de perdre le contexte
pour comprendre
la personne
et l'œuvre de Christ
qui se trouve
dans l'Ancien Testament
parce que l'Ancien Testament
parle de Christ.
Même lorsque Dieu
est en train
de créer le monde,
quand il crée le monde,
le monde parle déjà
de Christ.
Le travail de la création,
la rébellion
de l'humanité
contre Dieu,
les conséquences
du péché,
le fait que Dieu
va élire un peuple
en particulier
à qui il va confier
ses oracles,
toutes ces choses-là
préparées
à la venue
de Christ.
Par la suite même,
et c'est là,
par exemple,
quand on voit
le problème
que Martian avait,
par la suite,
quand nous regardons
les confrontations
que le Seigneur Jésus-Christ
va avoir avec les pharisiens,
quand nous voyons
les confrontations
qu'il avait avec les pharisiens,
c'était par rapport
à une compréhension,
à la façon
de comprendre la loi.
les épîtres,
toutes les épîtres,
quand vous lisez
les épîtres,
les livres,
les épîtres écrits
par Paul,
par Pierre,
par Jacques,
par Jean,
vous allez voir
que toutes les références,
ils les prennent où ?
Dans l'Ancien Testament.
L'Ancien Testament
était la Bible
du Seigneur Jésus-Christ,
elle était la Bible
des apôtres.
Donc,
au moment où quelqu'un
va dire,
au moment qu'il ne considère
pas l'Ancien Testament
comme étant important,
il est en train
de faire une erreur
très grave.
Donc,
dans le cadre
des promesses
qui sont faites,
nous allons voir
trois points
quand on nous parle
des promesses
qui sont faites.
On va voir
qu'il y a déjà
une histoire particulière.
On va voir
la passion,
on va dire,
la passion que Dieu
a pour la sainteté
et on va voir
la promesse d'espoir.
Donc,
pourquoi l'Ancien Testament
parle de promesses
qui sont faites ?
La Bible commence par Genèse,
chapitre 1,
verset 1.
Et qu'est-ce que la Bible
nous dit à un moment ?
Elle nous stipule
qu'au commencement,
Dieu créa les cieux
et la terre.
Dieu a créé
toutes les choses
à partir de rien.
Déjà,
avant même
la venue du Seigneur
Jésus-Christ,
c'est le plus grand miracle
que nous observons
dans la Bible.
Le plus grand miracle,
c'est que Dieu
ait créé quelque chose
à partir de rien.
Lorsque nous lisons
les trois premiers chapitres
de Genèse,
vous avez déjà,
je pense que tout le monde
a déjà dû lire
les trois premiers chapitres
de Genèse.
Quand nous lisons
les trois premiers chapitres
de Genèse,
il nous parle de la création,
il nous parle de la venue
de l'homme,
il nous parle de la chute.
Et nous voyons à un moment
que ces trois chapitres
sont très importants,
très très importants
pour comprendre
le monde
dans lequel nous sommes.
Si à un moment
nous négligeons
les trois premiers chapitres
de Genèse,
nous allons avoir
une vision faussée
de ce que Dieu fait,
nous allons avoir
une vision faussée
quand nous voyons
même le mal
dans le monde.
Parce que quand des personnes
se permettent de dire
« Mais pourquoi Dieu
laisse l'injustice ?
Pourquoi Dieu
permet telle ou telle chose ? »
Ça, ce sont des gens
qui n'ont jamais lu
les trois premiers chapitres
de Genèse.
Mais quand nous lisons
les trois premiers chapitres
de Genèse,
tout ce que nous voyons
autour de nous
prend sens.
L'histoire particulière
qui nous permet
de comprendre
pourquoi des promesses
ont été faites,
vous avez l'histoire
d'Adam et Ève,
de Caïen et Abel,
vous avez le déluge
avec Noé,
le déluge va intervenir
pourquoi ?
Parce qu'à un moment
le mal va se répandre
de plus en plus
et Dieu va décider
de juger.
Vous avez la tour
de Babel,
vous avez Abraham,
Moïse et l'Exode.
Là je suis en train
de faire un résumé succinct
de l'Ancien Testament.
Donc si je devais résumer
l'Ancien Testament,
c'est l'histoire
d'Adam et Ève,
Caïen et Abel,
le déluge,
la tour de Babel,
Abraham,
Moïse et l'Exode,
ensuite la loi,
Josué et les juges,
la période de royauté
et pendant cette période
de royauté,
il va y avoir
l'idolâtrie d'Israël
et la destruction
des deux royaumes,
l'exil à Babylone,
le retour de l'exil
de Babylone,
le reste qui revient
et qui va rétablir
le temple,
mais ce ne sera plus
la gloire
du premier temple.
Voilà comment
on pourrait déjà
résumer l'Ancien Testament.
Dans l'Ancien Testament,
c'est une histoire particulière.
L'Ancien Testament,
c'est une histoire particulière
dans le sens
où Dieu
va se choisir
un peuple
qu'il va
prendre
pour pouvoir
préparer
la venue du Messie.
Donc,
dans l'Ancien Testament,
nous avons
39 livres.
Aujourd'hui,
on va juste parcourir
en reviendrant
en détail
sur chacun
de ces livres.
Il y a 5 livres
qui constituent
le Pentateuch.
Donc,
on peut les appeler
les 5 livres
de la loi.
Là,
c'est beaucoup
plus facile
aussi à donner.
Donc,
on a la Genèse,
on a Genèse,
Exode,
Nombre,
Lévitique,
Deutéronome.
Donc,
ce sont les 5 livres
de la loi.
Nous avons 12 livres
qu'on appelle
les livres historiques.
Ce sont des livres
qui vont de Josué
à Esther.
Donc,
ils comprennent Josué,
les juges,
et ils vont jusqu'à
cette période
de l'exil
à Babylone.
Donc,
les 17 livres,
quand on considère
c'est-à-dire
les 5 livres
du Pentateuch,
plus les 12 livres
historiques,
vous avez
une période
de l'histoire
qui va de la création
du monde
jusqu'à l'exil
et au retour
de l'exil
de Babylone.
Nous avons 5 livres
dans l'Ancien Testament
qui évoquent
des aspects
d'expérience
avec Dieu.
Donc,
ce sont ces livres
qu'on connaît
les Job,
Psaume,
Proverbe,
Ecclésiaste,
Cantique des Cantiques.
À la suite
de ces livres,
nous avons une série
de 17 livres
qui vont commencer
d'Esaïe
et qui finissent
à Malachi,
qui est le dernier livre
de l'Ancien Testament,
mais qui,
chronologiquement,
on verra ça plus tard,
n'est pas forcément
le dernier livre.
Parce que le dernier livre,
je crois que si je ne me trompe pas,
c'est entre Néhémie et Esdras.
Parce qu'à un moment,
Malachi va prophétiser,
le moment va prophétiser
sur une période avant.
Mais en tout cas,
dans la Bible,
on voit un moment
que nous allons clore
cette série de 17 livres
qui va avec les prophètes
va être clôturée
avec Malachi.
Donc,
ce sont les livres
des prophètes.
Ces livres,
même cet ensemble
de livres,
sont très importants
parce qu'ils nous permettent
de comprendre
au travers de la Bible
comment Dieu,
donc l'ensemble
de ces livres
qu'on prend de la création
jusqu'à Malachi,
ces livres nous permettent
de comprendre
comment Dieu a travaillé
avec un peuple en particulier
pendant des siècles,
comment il les a traités,
comment ce peuple
a répondu
à la façon
dont il les traitait.
Et c'est ça
qui nous amène aussi
au deuxième point.
Donc,
quand on parle
des promesses
qui sont faites,
nous voyons déjà
que Dieu voit un besoin,
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a
la chute de l'homme.
Là,
je vous ai illustré
quelques épisodes.
Il y a l'épisode
d'Adam et Ève,
il y a la confirmation
avec Caïen et Abel,
il y a le déluge.
On voit la chute de l'homme
et on voit un moment
que l'homme a perdu,
l'homme a perdu
le lien qu'il avait
avec Dieu.
L'alliance même,
c'est important de préciser,
l'homme a perdu
l'alliance
qu'il avait établie
avec Dieu.
Dieu avait établi
une alliance
avec Adam
où chacun
devait respecter
le terme de l'alliance.
Et là,
Adam a échoué
à respecter
le terme de l'alliance.
Cette alliance
a été rompue.
Dans ce deuxième point,
donc déjà,
nous voyons à un moment
pourquoi Dieu va faire
des promesses
à cause de ce premier point-là
que nous voyons
de cette histoire particulière
qui nous témoigne déjà
de l'histoire de l'humanité.
Quand nous lisons
l'histoire d'Israël,
nous arrivons déjà
à voir une partie
de l'histoire de l'humanité.
Le deuxième point
pourquoi il y a eu
des promesses
qui ont été faites,
c'est la passion de Dieu
pour la sainteté.
Donc,
aujourd'hui encore,
un grand nombre
de personnes
vont associer
l'Ancien Testament
à un Dieu en colère.
Certains vont même penser
que le Dieu
de l'Ancien Testament
est un Dieu injuste.
Et souvent,
ils vont considérer
qu'ensuite,
il y a Jésus,
le Fils de Dieu,
qui lui est un peu plus gentil.
Ça,
c'est les chrétiens libéraux
qui vont considérer
à un moment
qu'il y a un Jésus
plus gentil,
même beaucoup plus tolérant.
Et puis,
il y a son papa
qui est très méchant,
qui juge le reste.
C'est vraiment comme ça
que certains voient.
Ils ne comprennent pas
à un moment
que c'est ce même Dieu.
Ce même Dieu.
Donc,
bien que ce soit
une vision erronée
que les gens ont de Dieu,
il y a quelque chose
qui doit être pris en compte.
La colère de Dieu
n'est pas celle
d'un tyran.
La colère de Dieu
est justifiée
parce que Dieu
place sa sainteté
au-dessus
de toute chose,
de toute autre chose.
Donc,
le péché,
quand nous parlons
du péché,
le péché est un affront
direct contre Dieu
et sa sainteté.
Donc,
nous voyons que
nous avons parlé
de cette alliance,
de ce principe
d'alliance
et Adam,
donc,
le péché,
c'est une violation
de l'alliance.
C'est-à-dire,
à un moment,
Dieu conclut une alliance
avec Adam
et Adam
viole l'alliance
au travers du péché.
Nous voyons
ce principe
de cette alliance
et ce que Dieu
va faire un moment,
tout au long
de l'histoire,
nous voyons des alliances,
nous voyons une alliance
avec Adam,
de Dieu avec Noé,
nous voyons une alliance
avec Abraham,
avec David,
avec plusieurs autres.
Mais ce qui ressort,
c'est-à-dire,
quand Dieu établit
l'alliance
avec Adam,
c'est une alliance
où Dieu respecte,
doit respecter
sa part du contrat
et Adam doit respecter
sa part du contrat.
Mais dès le moment
où Adam va pécher,
ce qui va se passer
maintenant,
c'est que quand Dieu
va établir une alliance
avec Noé,
avec Abraham,
avec David,
Dieu ne demande plus
de contrepartie
de ces hommes.
C'est Dieu
qui s'engage
maintenant
à accomplir
l'alliance.
Et voilà pourquoi
pour ceux
qui ont lu le passage,
quand vous pensez
à l'épisode
lorsque Dieu établit
l'alliance
avec Abraham,
qu'est-ce qui va se passer?
Au moment où Abraham
doit respecter sa part
en établissant
le contrat,
Dieu l'endort.
Abraham tombe
dans un profond sommeil
et les animaux
qui avaient été séparés
en deux
pour pouvoir faire
l'alliance,
il y a le feu de Dieu
qui passe entre les deux
et Dieu conclut l'alliance.
Mais Dieu n'engage pas
Abraham à respecter.
Pourquoi?
Parce qu'à un moment,
l'homme est maintenant
dans une situation
où à cause de son péché,
il est incapable
de pouvoir remplir
les exigences de Dieu.
et ça, déjà,
quand on regarde ça
dans l'Ancien Testament,
c'est déjà important
à comprendre
quand nous voyons
aujourd'hui des personnes
qui vont imaginer
un moment
que nous puissions
arriver au salut
par nos propres efforts.
Donc,
nous voyons
que les hommes
étaient pécheurs
et donc les hommes
ne pouvaient plus soutenir
leur part de l'alliance.
Donc, quelque part,
pour rétablir l'alliance,
il fallait
une réparation
et c'est là
où les sacrifices
rentrent.
C'est-à-dire,
le sacrifice permettait,
donc déjà,
à l'époque,
Dieu permet aussi
que les nations autour,
déjà,
le sacrifice
est déjà bien incorporé
dans la pensée.
C'est-à-dire que vous voyez
dès qu'Abel et Caïen,
vous voyez déjà
que les sacrifices
sont faits
pour pouvoir plaire à Dieu.
Donc, quelque part,
Dieu va utiliser
le moyen du sacrifice
comme étant un moyen
pour pouvoir
réparer
l'alliance
lorsque l'alliance
est cassée.
Donc, on voit
que dès la chute,
il y a déjà
le sacrifice
d'Abel et Caïen.
En Égypte,
avant que les enfants
d'Israël
ne sortent de l'Égypte,
on voit un moment
qu'ils vont être sauvés
à partir de quoi ?
À partir de sacrifices.
Il fallait
qu'ils sacrifient
un agneau pur
et sans tâches
qu'ils devaient manger
et le sang
devait être mis
sur les poteaux
et les linteaux.
Et lorsque l'ange
de l'éternel passait,
il épargnait
la famille du nouveau-né,
le nouveau-né
de la famille.
En passant,
il ne tuait pas
et c'est comme ça
qu'il a tué
les nouveaux-nés
des Égyptiens.
Il l'a préservé
à cause de quoi ?
À cause du sacrifice.
Lorsque nous lisons
Lévitique,
nous allons voir
alors Lévitique,
pour ceux qui ont déjà
lu Lévitique,
vous voyez que Lévitique
parle pratiquement
que de sacrifice.
Lévitique nous montre
comment les sacrifices
doivent être faits.
Quand nous regardons
la façon dont Dieu
va construire le temple,
même le design du temple,
ça nous enseigne déjà
quelque chose.
Le design du temple
est fait,
il y a le portique,
il y a le lieu saint
et il y a le lieu très saint.
Et dans le lieu très saint,
personne n'y entrait,
il n'y avait que
le souverain sacrificateur
qui y rentrait
une seule fois
dans l'année
pour pouvoir
accomplir
le jour
des expiations.
Donc,
les sacrifices
servaient à apaiser Dieu
en attendant
le sacrifice ultime.
C'est-à-dire,
qu'est-ce que Dieu
va enseigner
au travers de ça ?
C'est qu'à un moment,
Dieu
fait une promesse.
Lorsque Adam et Ève
pèchent,
la promesse est faite
qu'un jour,
Dieu va restaurer.
C'est-à-dire,
Dieu va restaurer
avec une nouvelle création
qui ne sera plus touchée
par le péché
et il est en train
de donner déjà
une consolation
à Adam et Ève.
Et voilà pourquoi
en attendant,
Adam et Ève
devaient déjà
faire des sacrifices
pour pouvoir
apaiser
la colère de Dieu
vis-à-vis du péché
en attendant
le sacrifice ultime.
Et voilà pourquoi
dans les indications,
c'était très important
où Dieu parlait
même déjà
qu'il fallait que l'animal
soit sans tâche
et sans défaut
parce que c'était
pour pointer vers Christ.
Donc,
si à un moment,
on n'a jamais lu
ce passage
de l'Ancien Testament
qui nous parle
de cet animal
qui doit être
sans défaut
et sans tâche,
nous perdons déjà
quelque chose.
Si nous n'étudions pas ça,
nous perdons déjà
une compréhension
de pourquoi Christ
devait naître,
par exemple,
d'une vierge
et ne pas naître
directement par Joseph.
Exode 34,
verset 6 à 7
nous dit
« Et l'Éternel
passa devant lui
et s'écria
« L'Éternel,
l'Éternel,
Dieu miséricordieux
et compatissant,
lent à la colère,
riche en bonté
et en fidélité,
qui conserve son amour
jusqu'à mille générations,
qui pardonne l'iniquité,
la rébellion
et le péché,
mais qui ne tient point
le coupable
pour innocent
et qui punit
l'iniquité des pères
sur les enfants
et sur les enfants
des enfants
jusqu'à la troisième
et à la quatrième génération. »
Quand nous lisons ce passage,
la question que nous nous posons
c'est de nous dire
comment un Dieu
qui ne peut pardonner
un coupable
peut-il néanmoins pardonner ?
Donc là encore
nous sommes toujours
dans les promesses faites
dans l'Ancien Testament.
Nous avons vu en premier lieu
que Dieu utilise
un peuple particulier
pour déjà nous enseigner
l'histoire de l'humanité,
pour comprendre
l'histoire de l'humanité.
Dieu utilise un moment
ce principe
de la sainteté
pour nous enseigner
l'importance du sacrifice
et maintenant
par cette importance
du sacrifice
les promesses
l'Ancien Testament
là où il est important
dans les promesses
qui sont faites
c'est que
il y a une promesse
d'espoir.
Donc j'ai déjà commencé
un peu à aborder ça.
L'amour
dans la promesse
d'espoir
l'amour n'est pas seulement
un aspect de la vie
du chrétien
l'amour c'est un aspect
biblique.
Et donc je reprécise
le Dieu de l'Ancien Testament
est, est aussi
et sera toujours
un Dieu d'amour
même envers ses ennemis.
En plusieurs endroits
dans l'Ancien Testament
ça c'est déjà
pour casser un peu
ce principe
où on a une idée
que Dieu est différent
dans l'Ancien Testament
il est plus doux
dans le nouveau nom.
Dans l'Ancien Testament
nous allons voir
un moment
que dans Deutéronome 6,5
Dieu va nous rappeler
comment nous devons l'aimer.
Je vous donne
les références
à cause du temps
dans Lévitique 19, verset 34
nous voyons comment
Dieu nous dit
d'aimer
demander aux Israélites
d'aimer leurs prochains
d'aimer l'étranger
donc nous voyons
que malgré la chute
dans le jardin d'Éden
malgré l'échec
d'Israël
nous voyons quand même
une manifestation
de la grâce
de l'amour de Dieu
une manifestation
de sa miséricorde
de sa patience
à une échelle
qui est inimaginable
pour nous.
Quand nous méditons
l'Ancien Testament
notre conclusion
c'est de nous dire
comment Dieu
a pu aimer
un peuple aussi rebelle
et comment Dieu
a continué
à manifester son amour
envers un peuple aussi rebelle
et qu'est-ce que Paul
nous dira ?
Il nous dira
prenez ça comme exemple
ne vous considérez pas
comme meilleur
que les Israélites
mais considérez
que vous êtes
dans la même situation
où l'amour de Dieu
est manifesté envers vous
alors que vous ne le méritez pas.
Dès la Genèse
comme je vous ai dit
nous voyons la promesse
d'un espoir
nous voyons un moment
que Dieu promet
le pardon
et la restauration
qui sera faite
c'est ce qu'on appelle
souvent le proto-évangile
et lorsqu'il y a
la naissance du Christ
vous voyez par exemple
quand les mages arrivent
ils parlent
qu'il y a une étoile
qui leur indique
que l'enfant est né
et Rod va demander
à ses spécialistes
ils vont lui confirmer
que le Messie doit arriver
donc au niveau
du peuple d'Israël
ils étaient dans cette confirmation
la promesse
qui a été faite
depuis Adam
a été préservée
pendant plusieurs siècles
et lorsque nous arrivons
à la naissance du Christ
nous voyons
que le peuple d'Israël
même si aujourd'hui
c'est une mauvaise compréhension
qu'ils ont
mais le peuple d'Israël
est dans l'attente
d'un sauveur
ils attendaient le prophète
parce que Moïse
l'avait annoncé
comme le prophète
Esaïe l'avait annoncé
comme le roi
Daniel l'avait annoncé
comme le fils de l'homme
qui venait sur des nuages
mais ce qu'il y a
c'est que le peuple d'Israël
avait gardé ses promesses
qui avaient été faites
et ils s'attendaient
à ce qu'elles s'accomplissent
ces promesses
donc étaient l'espoir
de l'Ancien Testament
ces promesses là
nous enseignaient à un moment
que le seul vrai espoir
de l'humanité
était l'accomplissement
de ces promesses
et c'est important
parce que même
quand l'humanité
aujourd'hui
qui est englobée
dans le péché
ne voyait pas encore
le plan de Dieu
Dieu est en train
de l'accomplir
et le souci
qu'il y aura plus tard
avec les Israélites
c'est qu'ils ne comprennent
pas un moment
que ce salut
était pour toute l'humanité
c'est encore là
une chose
qu'ils avaient raté
donc nous aurons l'occasion
pendant que nous allons
parcourir
les 39 livres
de l'Ancien Testament
nous allons revenir
à chaque livre
sur la promesse
qui a été faite
sur cet espoir
quand on parle
de cet espoir
que Dieu avait donné
tous ces livres
nous parlent de Christ
mais là je vais finir
quand même
aujourd'hui
avec la partie
je pense que plus tard
on reviendra là dessus
parce que c'est important
aussi de faire le lien
donc je vous ai parlé
des promesses
qui avaient été faites
l'humanité pêche
Dieu pourvoit
un moyen
de réparation
de l'alliance
au travers des sacrifices
mais ce moyen
est temporaire
en attendant
le sacrifice ultime
et la promesse
est faite
un jour
que le sacrifice ultime
sera fait
et que celui
qui va restaurer
toutes choses
viendra un jour
pour restaurer
quand nous lisons
le Nouveau Testament
maintenant on va aborder
rapidement
juste pour finir
aujourd'hui
quand nous lisons
le Nouveau Testament
maintenant nous voyons
l'accomplissement
de ses promesses
les promesses
sont faites
dans l'Ancien Testament
les promesses
sont accomplies
dans le Nouveau Testament
et ce qui doit
déjà nous encourager
c'est que
chacun de nous
si nous examinons
notre vie ici
nous allons constater
un moment
que nous avons déjà
eu à faire des promesses
à quelqu'un
à plusieurs personnes
nous n'avons pas
respecté ces promesses
!
les gens nous ont fait
des promesses
et les gens n'ont pas
respecté les promesses
et il faut souvent
nous en souvenir
lorsqu'on se plaint
des gens qui ne respectent
pas des promesses
que nous-mêmes
nous ne respectons
pas nos propres promesses
donc nous ne pouvons
pas placer notre confiance
en quoi que ce soit
ici-bas
et d'ailleurs
il y a les élections
qui arrivent
et je peux vous dire
à un moment
que les polysticiens
vont vous faire
beaucoup de promesses
qu'ils n'accompliront
pas du tout
mais nous pouvons
placer notre confiance
en Dieu
quand nous lisons
l'Ancien Testament
parce qu'il est le seul
à pouvoir accomplir
ses promesses
parfaitement
alors je n'ai pas
le chiffre exact
mais nous sommes
à près de 4000
prophéties
recensées
et accomplies
dans la Bible
dans l'Ancien Testament
près de 4000
avec tous les événements
difficiles
qui ont été traversés
je vous ai parlé
les enfants d'Israël
ont pu se demander
un moment
si la promesse
du Messie
était bien réelle
ce qui fait un moment
que pour certains
il y avait
une mauvaise compréhension
du Sauveur
mais Dieu
a bien accompli
ses promesses
pour comprendre
le principe
de ses promesses
qui ont été accomplies
nous devons
regarder à Christ
comme le Sauveur promis
nous devons regarder
la nouvelle alliance
qui a été établie
et nous devons
regarder au fait
qu'il y a une nouvelle création
qui a été faite
et je vais finir
avec ces trois points
le problème
des enfants d'Israël
à un moment
c'est que
à travers les sexes
ça c'est toujours normal
même là déjà
dans cette salle
si par exemple
je dis quelque chose
à Myriam
je donne une phrase
et je lui dis
de dire la même chose
à Joachim
si nous arrivons
à la fin
nous n'aurons pas
la même version
de la phrase
nous aurons quelque chose
de déformé
pas totalement exact
et le problème
c'est que
Dieu fait des promesses
claires
à un moment
à Adam
à Moïse
eux ils comprennent
le sens
à David
mais en traversant
les siècles
en traversant
les difficultés
le peuple d'Israël
perd un moment
oublie la loi
ils oublient
l'importance
de la loi
c'était que
les sacrifices
qu'ils étaient
en train de faire
devaient les amener
à comprendre
à un moment
qu'il faut qu'un jour
ça cesse
il faut qu'un jour
ils puissent arriver
à trouver ce repos
et voilà pourquoi
Paul va dire
à un moment
qu'en rejetant le Christ
ils ont rejeté
le repos
qui leur était offert
donc les prophéties
annoncées le Christ
donc sur le premier point
quand nous parlons
de comment ces promesses
ont été accomplies
dans le Nouveau Testament
nous voyons au moment
que le rédempteur
qui avait été promis
est arrivé
les prophéties
qui annonçaient
le Christ
ont été accomplies
là je vais vous lire
plusieurs passages
de la Bible
je vais donner aussi
des références
nous voyons dans
actes 15
13 à 18
lorsque Jacques
va parler
il va mettre
cette emphase
sur l'accomplissement
des prophéties
il va dire
lorsqu'ils ont cessé
de parler
Jacques prit la parole
et dit
homme frère
écoutez moi
Simon a raconté
comment Dieu
a d'abord jeté
les regards
sur les nations
pour choisir
du milieu d'elles
un peuple
qui porta son nom
et avec cela
s'accordent
les paroles
des prophètes
selon qui il est écrit
après cela
je reviendrai
et je relèverai
de sa chute
l'attente de David
j'en sais
réparerai
les ruines
et je la redresserai
afin que le reste
des hommes
cherche le Seigneur
vous voyez
la promesse
n'était pas juste
une compréhension
pour un peuple
en particulier
la promesse
était cette restauration
de toute l'humanité
afin que le reste
des hommes
cherche le Seigneur
ainsi que toutes
les nations
sur lesquelles
mon nom est invoqué
dit le Seigneur
qui fait ces choses
à qui elles sont
connues de toute éternité
donc quand nous lisons
le Nouveau Testament
nous voyons
que les auteurs
du Nouveau Testament
vont décrire
le Seigneur Jésus Christ
comme le nouvel Adam
la référence
1 Corinthiens 15
45 à 47
ils vont
ils vont décrire
le Seigneur Jésus Christ
comme le juste
qui est annoncé
dans l'Ancien Testament
quand vous lisez
le livre des psaumes
vous allez voir
à un moment
que dans le livre des psaumes
on parle du juste
le juste
mais qu'est-ce que les psaumes
sont en train de mettre
c'est que quand nous lisons
les psaumes
la Bible
et même quand nous
voyons la loi
aucun homme n'était capable
d'accomplir parfaitement
la loi
et quand la Bible
parle du juste
dans le livre des psaumes
elle parle de celui
qui est capable
d'accomplir parfaitement
la loi
et donc quand elle parlait
du juste dans les psaumes
elle ne parlait pas
de ceux qui feraient
des efforts
pour accomplir
la loi
elle était en train
de parler de Christ
qui allait accomplir
parfaitement la loi
et donc la Bible
va nous dire un moment
donc dans 1 Pierre 3
par exemple
verset 18
Pierre va dire un moment
que c'est ce juste
dont les écritures parlent
qui est arrivé
la Bible souligne un moment
dans le Nouveau Testament
elle va souligner
que Jésus
est plus grand que Moïse
elle va souligner
même un moment
que Abraham
s'était réjoui
de l'arrivée du Christ
ça nous sommes dans
Jean 8
56 à 58
et un moment
dans Luc 24
verset 27
on va nous mettre
l'emphase sur le fait
que Christ
est le centre
des écritures
toutes les écritures
parlent de lui
en lui
Dieu
alors je vous ai parlé
de ces alliances
tout au long de l'histoire
où Dieu a fait
des alliances
avec les hommes
et les hommes
étaient incapables
de pouvoir accomplir
ces alliances
et cette alliance
à un moment
il y avait cette alliance
de la loi
où le peuple d'Israël
a été incapable
d'accomplir la loi
et voilà pourquoi
le jugement est tombé
mais Dieu avait fait
une promesse
Dieu avait fait
à un moment
que la relation
allait être restaurée
et que Dieu allait
maintenant se créer
un nouveau peuple
le peuple
qui aurait dû être créé
à partir d'Adam
ça avait échoué
un moment
quand Dieu prend le peuple
il le sort d'Egypte
il veut créer
une nouvelle nation
il n'était pas
c'était pas destiné
les Lévites
n'étaient pas à la base
destinés à être
les seuls sacrificateurs
Dieu avait destiné
que c'était toute la nation
qui devait être
des sacrificateurs
mais dès l'instant
où le reste des tribus
a été plongé
dans le péché
Dieu a choisi
les Lévites
et donc là déjà encore
c'est une alliance
qui avait échoué
mais maintenant
il y a une alliance
excellente
qui va être accomplie
et un peuple nouveau
va sortir de cette alliance
et cette alliance
c'est Christ
qui va l'accomplir
et voilà pourquoi
le Seigneur Jésus Christ
je donne les références
vous pouvez relire
dans Jean 2 verset 19
Jésus leur répondit
détruisez ce temple
et en trois jours
je le relèverai
il est en train de parler
de l'alliance nouvelle
qu'il allait mettre en place
dans Luc 24
45 à 47
il dit
alors il leur ouvrit
l'esprit
afin qu'ils comprissent
les écritures
et il leur dit
ainsi il est écrit
que le Christ souffrirait
et qu'il ressusciterait
des morts
le troisième jour
et que la repentance
et le pardon des péchés
seraient prêchés
en son nom
à toutes les nations
à commencer par Jérusalem
Marc 10 verset 45
nous souligne à un moment
que le Seigneur Jésus Christ
est venu en ronçon
pour plusieurs
ce que nous devons comprendre
de la nouvelle alliance
que Christ établit
c'est que
le lion de Juda
est devenu
l'agneau sacrifié
pour nos péchés
par le fait que Christ
c'est à dire que
le Seigneur Jésus Christ
est venu maintenant
les promesses
de l'Ancien Testament
qui sont accomplies
c'est que le sacrifice
ultime est là
c'est à dire Dieu
parce qu'il n'y avait
que Dieu
qui pouvait finalement
pouvoir être
à la hauteur
de ses standards
Dieu s'est fait homme
Dieu était homme
le Seigneur Jésus Christ
était pleinement homme
il a vécu une vie d'homme
il a vécu
les tentations du péché
mais il n'a point péché
et il a triomphé
il a triomphé du péché
et voilà pourquoi
il a été ressuscité
quand il est mort
et parce qu'il a été
ressuscité
par son acte
de substitution
quand il a été
ressuscité
alors il a pu maintenant
être le sacrifice
ultime
que les enfants
d'Israël faisaient
pendant plusieurs siècles
il a été le sacrifice
ultime pour nous
sinon nous serions
obligés aujourd'hui
de devoir faire aussi
encore des sacrifices
donc par son acte
de substitution
le Seigneur Jésus Christ
nous a racheté
par son sang
je vous laisse lire
chapitre 20
verset 28
qui est aussi très important
où Paul va parler
un moment
il va dire
prenez donc garde
à vous-même
et à tout le troupeau
sur lequel le Saint-Esprit
vous a établi évêque
pour paître
l'église du Seigneur
qui s'est acquise
par son propre sang
ce qui avait échoué
avec l'ancienne alliance
s'est accompli en Christ
à partir de Christ
une nation sainte
un peuple qui le loue
avec un cœur pur
dans la sainteté
est né
et c'est là
où nous parlons
de la nouvelle alliance
en Christ
c'est une nouvelle alliance
où là encore
c'est Dieu
qui fournit
l'accomplissement
de l'alliance
et la seule chose
que l'homme a à faire
c'est de pouvoir
avoir la foi
et enfin nous allons finir
quand nous parlons
de comment nous voyons
la promesse
de l'Ancien Testament
qui a été accomplie
dans l'Apocalypse
je pense que
chacun de vous
a déjà pu lire
Apocalypse
Apocalypse nous parle
de nouveaux cieux
et d'une nouvelle terre
et ce que Apocalypse
marque
c'est que
le début de la nouvelle création
commence à quel moment ?
Le début de la nouvelle création
commence à la résurrection
du Seigneur Jésus Christ
dès l'instant
où le Seigneur Jésus Christ
est ressuscité
il est ressuscité
à cause de quoi ?
à cause de sa justice
si Christ n'avait pas été juste
Dieu ne l'aurait pas
ressuscité des morts
mais parce qu'il a été juste
Dieu le ressuscite
et à partir de là
Dieu lui dit
tu es maintenant digne
de pouvoir être
celui qui règne
de toute éternité
et il régnait déjà
mais maintenant
dans l'accomplissement parfait
Christ
dans sa nature humaine
a été l'homme
qui a été capable
de pouvoir restaurer
les choses
que Adam avait perdues
Apocalypse 21
verset 3 à 5
nous dit
j'entendis du trône
une voix forte
qui disait
et ça vous voyez
ça c'est la conclusion
de tout ce que nous venons
de parcourir
l'Ancien Testament
nous parle
des promesses
qui sont faites
les promesses sont accomplies
et voilà la promesse ultime
j'entendis du trône
une voix forte
qui disait
voici le tabernacle
de Dieu avec les hommes
il habitera avec eux
et ils seront son peuple
et Dieu lui-même
sera avec eux
il essuiera
toute l'arme
de leurs yeux
et la mort ne sera plus
et il n'y aura plus
ni deuil
ni cri
ni douleur
car les premières choses
ont disparu
et celui qui était assis
sur le trône dit
voici je fais
toutes choses nouvelles
et il dit
écrit
car ces paroles
sont certaines
et véritables
ces paroles
sont certaines
et véritables
je vous ai parlé
de l'Ancien Testament
qui recense
près de 4000 prophéties
qui ont été accomplies
si nous voyons
un Dieu
qui a été capable
d'accomplir
d'être fidèle
dans cette première partie
de l'histoire
nous savons
nous n'avons aucun doute
qu'il sera capable
d'être fidèle
dans cette seconde partie
de l'histoire
et même là
ce qui est encore plus glorieux
c'est que
par rapport à ce qui avait été fait
avec Adam
nous sommes en train
d'hériter de quelque chose
d'encore plus glorieux
la nouvelle création
c'est une gloire
encore plus grande
que l'alliance
qui avait été établie
avec Adam
et si nous ne lisons pas
l'Ancien Testament
nous ne pouvons pas comprendre
donc en conclusion
pour aujourd'hui
ce qui est important
pour nous de voir
c'est que
Dieu dans sa souveraineté
ne va pas toujours agir
tel que nous l'entendons
et là je peux vous prendre
encore l'exemple
face aux épreuves
le peuple d'Israël
avait mal compris
ils espéraient un chef
qui allait les délivrer
de l'oppression militaire
ils n'avaient pas compris
à un moment
que le plus important
pour eux
était d'être sauvé
de leur péché
parce que c'était
la chose la plus importante
nous devons être conscients
à un moment
que souvent
il se peut que
à cause des circonstances
de vie
des épreuves
de beaucoup de choses
nous allons vivre
des déceptions
et ces déceptions
peuvent nous amener
à un moment
à ne pas considérer
la parole de Dieu
à sa juste valeur
ces déceptions
ces choses qui nous affectent
vont nous emmener
peut-être même
à ne pas considérer
même là
je vous ai parlé
de près de 4000 promesses
qui ont été accomplies
mais il se peut que demain
lorsque nous allons
avoir une situation difficile
nous allons oublier la Bible
nous allons un peu paniquer
par rapport à la situation
mais pour nous chrétiens
lorsque nous sommes en train
d'observer l'Ancien Testament
que nous voyons
toutes ces promesses
qui ont été faites
et que nous trouvons
leur accomplissement
dans le Nouveau Testament
la seule chose
qui doit poindre
dans notre cœur
et j'ai pris le passage
biblique
je crois
c'est dans Romains
Romains 11-33
je crois
voilà ce que Paul dit
et voilà ce qui doit être
l'attitude de notre cœur
au profondeur
de la richesse
de la sagesse
et de la science de Dieu
que ces jugements
soient insondables
et ça je le dis
nous pouvons lire
l'Ancien Testament
je vous encourage
à lire l'Ancien Testament
il y aura des parties
de l'Ancien Testament
qui seront difficiles
mais le plus important
pour nous
c'est un moment
que quand il y aura
des parties
où Dieu a choisi
dans sa souveraineté
de ne pas expliquer
pourquoi il a permis
ces choses
la seule conclusion
à laquelle nous devons arriver
c'est de réaliser
la profondeur
de la richesse
de la sagesse
de la science de Dieu
c'est de réaliser
que ces jugements
sont insondables
et ces voix
sont incompréhensibles
aucun de nous
n'a connu
la pensée du Seigneur
aucun de nous
n'a été son conseiller
ne lui a donné
en premier
pour qu'il ait
à recevoir en retour
c'est ce que nous dit
la parole
dans Romains 11
verset 33-36
c'est de lui
par lui
et pour lui
que sont toutes choses
à lui la gloire
dans tous les siècles
Amen
donc
nous ne sommes jamais
promptes
il peut arriver
à cause de certaines situations
que nous ne sommes jamais promptes
à pouvoir nous émerveiller
avec un tel passage
mais je vous encourage
lorsqu'à un moment
il y a des choses
qui sont difficiles
lorsqu'il y a des incompréhensions
je peux même dire
lorsque vous allez lire
l'Ancien Testament
sans le comprendre
et que Dieu peut vous paraître
un Dieu injuste
ou dur
je vous invite
à relire ce passage
de Romains 11
verset 33-36
et de réaliser un moment
que dans la profondeur
de la richesse
de la sagesse de Dieu
nous ne pouvons pas
tout comprendre
mais nous avons un Dieu
qui nous aime
et nous devons lui faire confiance
parce que c'est là aussi
la volonté de Dieu
pour nous
que nous puissions placer
notre confiance en lui
avec foi
gloire Dieu